aber wenn wir uns noch einmal die
situation anschauen zwischen denjenigen
die ja um das kanzleramt kämpfen und wir
haben gesehen einerseits immer daneben
den man ja immer so ein bisschen an
sieht mein gott er hätte es so gerne
gewollt markus söder und daran
anschließend die frage war auch söder
heute der bessere laschet ich fand ihn
verglichen mit seinen möglichkeiten
lustlos also der kann ganz anders der
hat zwar gut argumentiert und man konnte
ihm folgen und hat besser argumentiert
als laschet aber er hat nicht
herausgeragt aus der runde sondern er
wusste ja das rennen ist gelaufen der
der wusste auch in den umfragen liegt
scholz vorne er kennt die umfragen in
bayern die sind verheerend genauso
verheerend wie sie im bund sind also saß
ja auch mit gebeugtem rücken da und hat
sich noch ein bisschen mühe gegeben ich
will noch mal an roche anknüpfen weil
das ist für mich ein ganz interessanter
punkt dass wir müssen immer mal zwei
schritte zurücktreten und überlegen was
hammer überhaupt gesehen also er sagt
die wirken so als hätten sie ärgere die
haben alle schon miteinander regiert
haben sie aber nicht so wirken aber sie
merken so wälzen sich das ist vollkommen
richtig und es ist auch vollkommen
richtig dass der bundestag in den
letzten jahren den eindruck gemacht hat
als gäbe es da gar keine opposition das
ist sehr wichtig und da sage ich wenn
ich jetzt einen schritt zurückgeht das
sind eben die merkel jahre gewählt die
letzten merkel jahre waren so alle höhen
und tiefen eingeebnet man ist so
miteinander auf einem level mit einander
verkehrt es ist nichts aus dem ruder
gelaufen auch die linke waren bundestag
gut aufgehoben man hat ab und zu sich
mit der afg gestritten weil die hat noch
mal für ein kleinen skandal gesorgt aber
jetzt hoffen die afg abgesehen haben wir
heute abend gesehen wohin das führt
das ganze land ist merkel ließ ihre
kennst die kanzlerin lange glaubst du
disaster heute im kanzleramt und hat so
ein bisschen durchgesetzt und immer mal
wieder rein und herzlich gedacht mensch
wie macht der lasche das herz gottes
willen und weiß doch wieder es doch
wieder laschet ist deshalb wollte sie
ihn ja auch nicht die weiß dass er
langweilig ist das ist ja nicht neu ich
glaube sie hat sich das angeguckt und
motto anzog ist wahrscheinlich hat so
eine bulette dazu gegessen es ist sehr
sehr gerne mit kartoffelsalat und sich
wird ein glas wein wahrscheinlich oder
aber so dass weniger vorher war eine
interessante info die alte kunst gesagt
das ist aber nicht so sonderlich
animierend was die hier abliefern
diese merkel jahre müssen jetzt nicht
nur numerisch zu ende gehen die müssen
auch vom inhalt her zu ende gehen und
wir müssen zu anderen formen des umgangs
der politik miteinander und des umgangs
der medien mit der politik häufig diesen
punkt war scharf doliwa das ist wirklich
ein ganz entscheidender punkt ich habe
hier gearbeitet in den 2000er jahren gab
ein paar regierungswechsel gesehen in
deutschland und ich war immer etwas frau
pia durch es gibt waren und da gibt es
eine neue regierung aber du kannst
eigentlich die politik der neuen
regierung wenn du tief unterscheiden
will es von der roten regierung musst du
das elektronenmikroskop rausnehmen und
jetzt haben wir viele gesagt deutschland
braucht und das ist eine richtungswahl
wir machen eine richtungswahl ich war
bei herr laschet hat das auch gesagt und
ich muss sagen deutschland hätte eine
richtungswahl verdient dass man gesagt
hätte okay hier sind wir wir sagen nein
zu dieser verrückten klimapolitik die
grüne machen das nein zu mehr
enteignungen zu diesen ganzen
interventionismus da hat auch ein super
gemessen an dem was er verkörpern möchte
auch nicht überzeugt und das ist dann
wirklich entscheidender punkt wenn du in
einer demokratie lebst in der es nicht
mehr verschiedene klar erkennbare
richtungen gibt ist keine richtung mehr
gibt es keine demokratie mehr und noch
ein weiterer punkt das beobachte ich
weiß nicht wie er das wahrnehmen das
spürt ihr natürlich genau ich beobachte
in deutschland eine gefährliche tendenz
dass opposition andere meinung sofort
kriminalisiert werden und dafür war die
einstiegs debatte relevant weil diese
fürchterliche bluttat an diese
tankstelle das ist wirklich schlimm aber
was mich fast noch mehr entsetzt dort
ist wie eigentlich alle fast alle
politiker der in der runde diese tat
schon sozusagen für allgemeine tagen
pauschalisiert haben und jeden
oppositionellen jeden quer denken was
ist denn das müssen alle geradeaus
denken darf man gar nicht mehr quer
denken versucht haben da in eine tiefe
ecke zu stellen und das ist ein ungutes
auch aufbau oder nebenwirkungsprofil
merkel jahre es ist open gegen die
regierung zu sein dann bist du bereits
im giftschrank bist du ein querdenker
denkst du nicht mehr geradeaus also
deutschland braucht mehr quert aber die
proben sie ist aus doch am tisch
das ist alles ganz sicher ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe jetzt immer
gewartet auf grund von unserer
diskussionen die wir schon hatten oder
gesagt diese häufte das wirklich eine
schlimme partei und alles und so und ich
muss sagen die haben ihre chance heute
auch nicht gepackt um zu zeigen wo ist
sie eigentlich die große alternative
sind will aber noch mal auf diese lasche
söder variante zurückkommen das schon
ding dass einer wie armin laschet offen
darüber nachdenkt zweiter zu werden also
wir müssen das mal vorstellen
deutschland ist im endspiel der fußball
weltmeisterschaft und der trainer
gemachte pressekontakt
wenn wir heute an verlieren dann geht
die welt auch nicht
vorstellen dass so vorstellt wissen wie
es jetzt jedem cdu-wähler jedem
cdu-mitglied jedem cdu-wahlkämpfer jedem
cdu junge unions menschen geht wenn sie
diesen mann sehen der
das ist wirklich also den in dem das
muss und das geht mir wirklich nicht ein
und das finde ich spricht halt jetzt
heute abend war
verhältnismäßig ruhig doch für söder das
muss
da gab es die sender den monolog
sozusagen von markus söder
wo er gezeigt hat was er möchte
wie viele gute trelle schon also da
passiert genau das gleiche es geht genau
los wie bei lafontaine und schröder
viele viele ideen viele viele
experimente am ende stand das land kurz
vor dem ruin das darf nicht passieren
wir wollen was was macht markus söder
für ein dauerhaft ich ja er wäre
natürlich der bessere kandidat gewesen
das muss man sagen bei der wahl geht so
macht und sünder ist definitiv der
bessere machtpolitiker von den beiden er
hat sich jetzt heute zurückgehalten weil
er weiß wenn die beiden sich noch länger
streiten dann schwächt er laschet weiter
weiter weiter also er hat im sinne der
union burka man tage vor der wahl
aufhören
und wir wissen ja aber nicht bei der
union
ich will nur
warum hat er einmal gesagt das ist im
auge haben ihn lasse da stimme ich armin
laschet oder damit wollen wir beide doch
das gleich bei mir nicht so zum beispiel
der armin laschet heute von ganz ganz
großer bedeutung sein können warum mit
letzten jahr hat ihm doch von hinten
schon ein tintenfass aufs hemd
geschüttet dass er merkt das gar nicht
also schon gebrandmarkt ist als als
verlierer und wenn es passiert ist dann
geht es über ihn her als der anwender
armin laschet wirklich rauskommt als
verlierer dann ist er innerhalb
kürzester zeit kein cdu-vorsitzender
mehr und dann dauert es vielleicht ein
vierteljahr bis ein halbes jahr ist auch
kein ministerpräsident in nrw mehr
[Musik]